[Music]
worst fashion moment of the bow and the
top and growling get to pick wine just
once
the worst I would probably have to say
when it's been the sponge dress episode
whiny moany exchange mone exchanging the
sponge we all love to hate the spun
dress the sponge dress
I'm so sorry mone it was a bad dress and
this fun dress was the greatest fashion
moment see this this is the dirty
through the Southside anybody get that
it was so bad that it was good so the
sponge dress it's like Hanukkah
everybody in the world knows that I hate
that goddamn Tweety outfit I hate it and
I could say that openly because every
time I see a chai give her a big hug I'd
be like girl it's good to see you again
Tweety I love you you know I'm saying I
am just modeling and living my Tweety
Bird fantasies unfortunately Dusty's by
the runway will always be my go-to
runway that just did not really take
flight for me miss a brown cow stunning
I was like seriously girl that was a
spotted like that that's a giraffe
I saw the members like Oh brown cow's
stomach
Monique brown cow moment was a little
mess not a highlight in her life
probably my sister Monique mermaid it
was probably yeah one of my least
favorite things
calorie passed draft yeah I think that I
was a little unimpressed with Yuhas best
drag look because I know you Hall has a
different level of drag then we got to
see during that look sadly I'm gonna
give you real tea because I know you
want it I would take Cameron Michaels
gentleman's island look was made with a
glitter got the couldn't fabric that is
literally the cheapest thing you can
ever put on a drag queen
so that was questionable since I went
home on my paint denim and diamonds I'll
say that was the weakest one least
favorite fashion moment of the season
the Barbies in the flowers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]